it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what they Hey
welcome to the movie it's live everybody
we're doing it just want to give a shout
out to hashtag Owl nation whoo whoo
Perceval the owl in the house you guys
we've got an exciting movie fights for
you we've got three formidable
competitors let's meet them
first off he's always running the board
running the booth pressing the buttons
making things go he's come out from
behind the curtain and now he's here jte
host of JT movie thanks thank you very
much for the plug yeah uh yeah I'm back
I had an accident if you could see a
chipped tooth but I'm gonna use this
jagged tooth to go for the jugular I'll
go for the gold here buddy whoa you're
gonna fight jagged tooth is digging to
you with my movies now can I can I
resign there's no resigning in movies
good luck defending yourself against
JT's new jagged to terrifying our second
player you know him as the professor
from the Schmo down and all over the
Internet's welcome to movie fight salon
Harris thank you so much also a pillar
of owl nation one of the co-founder of
ala nation absolutely you are I mean
you're like a Rear Admiral yeah you're
are your fearless leader I'm like the
sergeant-at-arms hell yeah I don't know
what that does thank you for being a
cool again anytime
every time and last but not least you
know from hyper RPG and he's a good
friend of the show Cameron Rice hello
thank you for having back a Happy New
Year everybody
um Cameron did you have a good new year
pretty good we're shooting this in
December this is a real yes Cameron what
do you think was the most exciting thing
to happen on the week between Christmas
and New Year's yeah all the the Sun
bleeding Sun bleeding was was it that
was bad oh yeah this is Jay yeah that's
what the JT's dance floor jagged - yes
there was an epic solar mishap you guys
are doing battle and deciding this fight
we have judges we have fact checkers max
rad max rad we have producer max - max
Dion how's it going brother
it's going great I will still recovering
from the that son tear oh yeah that epic
solar tear glasses now so that we all
remember how
and Danielle Radford Danielle happy new
years as you all we know this is not
actually taped live but please do keep
contributing all of your alternate
answers and stories on the movie fights
live hashtag we love going through those
and reading them so yeah and yeah you
know hopefully none of us died in the
next two fingers crossed we're not
airing someone's posthumous movie watch
me be the water - oh God for good don't
let it be Danielle and Danielle so there
there are no poles there is no there is
no user pulled this week Danielle will
be deciding her own thoughts and
opinions on each battle I will and Max
was not prepared to be giving his own
opinions today yeah I'm not used to
giving opinions on things so we'll see
how this goes I don't really have a lot
of opinions
you know what just follow your heart
mother ma'am just follow your heart or
your mind that you know there's more
than one right what my question is if if
JT kills somebody then can a dead person
argue back work but here's the thing
if he kills them after they had already
delivered just such a great argument you
could still give a dead person the point
got it okay good I don't know how how
well that dead person will fare in the
speed round
it's no good so again how this game
works first person of four points wins
there are three regular round questions
then the two top scores will continue on
to the speed round where it's anybody's
ballgame so I'm going to be down three
oh and make a furious comeback to take
it for three
who the heck knows all I know is Billy
drop that sick ass package
Thank You Thor all right question number
one oh it's 2019 right now a lot of
movies coming out in 2019 we're asking a
really hard question I don't know if
there's any way to get this right but
they're gonna give their best guesses
what will be the best movie of 2019 how
about it let's start with player number
one JTG it's a tough question there's a
lot of good movies come out the movies
you guys have chosen
I am definitely looking forward to but I
am going to go with Avengers and game to
me this is the return of the king of the
Marvel Universe
that movie was awarded the best picture
because it was the culmination of this
long story that started off with
fellowship the rings and two towers for
me and game is literally that it's an
end game I feel like Marvel is putting
all their chips in there's good some
real losses ain't gonna be the snap and
some people are just gonna be able to
come back some phantom zone I really
feel like we're gonna lose some people
there's gonna be some heartfelt moments
some touching moments this will probably
be the first Marvel film where I just
ball I almost bought an Iron Man 2
hiding and I almost bought the Spider
Man died I know a lot of people did but
I kept it together but this one is gonna
be it's gonna have the emotional punch I
think some two other films didn't quite
have and for me it's gonna be the best
movie of the year I cried during ant-man
what part I'm sinking while it's all the
way up that's how it lost he's
recreating our favorite seas from at me
yes what does it make people cry like my
argument
I'm gonna have everybody stricken yes
you know I I was gonna go into an a-hole
bit why why I cried during ant-man but
I'm gonna skip it now share debacle you
can message me at how run do you want to
hear my whole ant-man bit jte thank you
for coming in with Avengers endgame lon
what you got I'm picking a little movie
Netflix is releasing it sometime this
year it's called the Irishman now this
movie is the new one for Martin Scorsese
so already a new Scorsese movie it's an
event they don't happen every year
he's selective about what projects he
makes already this would be exciting but
this movie reteam Scorsese with Robert
De Niro Harvey Keitel and Joe Pesci Joe
Pesci retired from acting he came back
to acting to be in this movie it also as
you saw from that screenshot they just
put up this is gonna be Scorsese's very
first time working with Al Pacino the
legendary Al Pacino if you were just
saying Scorsese and Al Pacino are gonna
get together and make a new movie this
year already it would be a must-see for
almost everything but there's more this
is a longtime passion project for
Scorsese he's been trying to get this
movie made for many years and it's
finally coming together this is the
biggest budget of Martin Scorsese's
career 175 million dollars on this movie
it's based on a true crime story other
famous true crime movies made by
Scorsese include Goodfellas Casino The
Departed the wolf on Wall Street pretty
good pedigree and it was shot by
Scorsese's frequent collaborator Rodrigo
Prieto he also shot Amore's perros
Brokeback Mountain and silence for
Scorsese which was an amazing looking
film a few years ago this movie has a
lot going for it also Island on this did
you guys know that this movie features
Jim Norton playing young Don Rickles
that's perfect casting and that's an
example of the kind of fun that we're
gonna have watching the Irishman I'm
totally in alright
Longwood Scorsese's the Irishman Cameron
alright I'm going with a another
director who doesn't do a lot of movies
is pretty selective fact this is his
ninth of what he says is gonna be a 10
films and then he's done going with
Quentin Tarantino's Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood starring Leonardo DiCaprio
there it is and Brad Pitt as the leads
this would be him reuniting with
DiCaprio after Django Unchained and
with Brad Pitt after inglorious basterds
two of his more recent movies this movie
also has Al Pacino in it as well as well
as a Bruce Dern Margot Robbie and Luke
Perry Perry Madson Michael Madsen Madsen
and Kurt Russell there's a lot of the
Quinns arancino players in here
he's been filming it around the area I
think they just are actually wrapped
last month and it's Tarantino so you
know it's gonna be authentic and the
fact that he is returning to a more
modern time than his last couple movies
has me excited he hasn't done something
in it's a 70s but there's 62 70s but he
hasn't done something in this era really
since Jackie Brown so it's been about 20
plus years since he's done a more modern
film so I think there's a lot going for
this movie I'm very excited about it and
I can't wait to say why it's gonna be
the best compared to these two new three
films that I am genuinely excited for
all three of them so I want to hear you
guys fight it out first I gotta attack
Irishman the problem with that movie is
there's so much there's so much you got
rely on technology mmm this is what I
have most of this movie is gonna be them
de-aged I don't think we're at that
point where I can watch a movie
yes it's gets close with Marvel my
Marvel Studios is the best at it but
still you're still watching the moon
you're like oh yeah they're using the
aging effects there tons of movies use
the aging effects all the time and most
the time you don't even know it's but
it's for like a popcorn film or
something that's fun to to remix to
crime movie with DeNiro
oh it's gonna be fun since Scorsese it's
good all those movies I said Goodfellas
yeah super fun casino totally fun well
The Wall Street's practically not for me
the performances are the best thing
about some of those movies and while I'm
watching
Al Pacino da-jin De Niro so you know I
think Andy Serkis is a good actor and
those aren't good performances de-aging
you're taking an older actor and making
them look younger but you're not chained
you're not changing their performance
you're just digitally I think every
movie you watch there's digital anything
that you're not even noticing that's
happening it's not like opens the moon I
have yet to see a movie where someone is
acting with a DA's mega board
I didn't literally stop me frame
every movie that you watch is digitally
retouched all those images are digitally
retouched are a digitally retouched and
making somebody look 30 years ago or
there really isn't that huge of a kinds
of deleting that you're doing on a
regular movie and then using it to sort
of slightly make Michelle Pfeiffer look
a few years younger it's not that
different I don't want to have to I want
to concentrate on the performance and
actually see what the actor is doing
like they're really pulling off this
effect just critiquing her own style of
watching movies and while we're doing
that I would like to continue critiquing
your style of what you started by saying
that you know well the Lord of the Rings
culminated Return of the King it's not
even the best movie in that trilogy the
first movie is the best movie in the
king is the one that gets hit it is like
I know a lot of people think return the
Kings is the best series it's not
definitively the best of the series by
any measure they're all good that series
is really until you get eternity killing
parsing an opinion here that has nothing
to do with adventures and games I'm
saying it proves the exact point he was
saying that Avengers endgame is gonna be
good because we've waited through all
these mediocre Marvel movies that lacks
stakes or whatever JT was saying leading
into this one and I'm saying his own
example of a franchise that built up to
a amazing conclusion was amazing the
whole way through just like the MCU has
been so my point really is that this is
just another Marvel movie where it's not
the culmination we got the culmination
and if you think about all is the
combination the combination is the snap
now we're just getting the resolution in
the leading into the next phase of
Marvel movies so this is the transition
movie where they end the show the guy
every TV season that you love what's the
best episode the best episode is episode
stop interrupting you jackass nonsense
the best
sort of a TV of the TV season is they'll
let the second one before the conclusion
that's when the shocking stuff happens
the finale just let's resolve this and
then segue into the next season
that's what Avengers endgame is gonna I
will say if there is a concern about the
da G makeup I believe there have been
some lots of photos of their possibly
the endgame might be a bit
time-traveling there might be a digit so
if you're knocking his Captain Marvel
which Samuel Jackson's the angel aloof
my movies not relying on it I mean
there's so many I'm sure a small part of
it is box your movie is heavily heavily
relying you don't know sing at that just
like we're guessing about endgame you
don't know my concern about the de-aging
that the aging wouldn't bother me my
concern about it is whether what which
company is Netflix hiring are they
hiring the company that does Marvel
which I believe Wetty does the D aging
on that or are they hiring Lucasfilm
where you're gonna get target but I mean
have you seen it do you know I have not
so that's a concern it's a concern it's
a good sir it's gonna be great it's
course do you think Martin Scorsese is
gonna be like oh this technology looks
horrible it's ruining my actors
performances let's put it in the movie
Martin Scorsese I have no authority here
let's put whatever garbage they send me
into the movie and it'll ruin Joe
Pesci's final film performance I would
like to say definitively once and for
all we've exhausted the D aging
lose point other than in your final can
we move under what's the time in
Hollywood cuz I do have some things I'd
like to say about that
first of all Cameron says you can always
count on quaint Tarantino because you
know the movie is gonna be authentic
that's the opposite of what he's doing
there the point is that they're not
authentic I wrote it down I wrote down
the word authentic out of thin air
movie's going to be authentic because
it's Tarantino and like Mel that's the
opposite of what it's gonna be I'll say
that but if I did can we play I guess
what I would say what I meant by
authentic is more using actual 70s cars
than that having a feel to its shooting
it on film I don't mean the Irishman is
gonna be period off integer but my point
is not about it being like and that's I
wasn't knocking the Irishman for a lack
of on to this is authenticity but I'm
not talking about the authenticity of
the actual things that happen in the
world because obviously an inglorious
basterds Hitler didn't die that way so
obviously Tarantino's gonna play with
stuff and that's what makes Tarantino
movies really exciting that they're that
they rarely happen when they happen
there's always something about him
there's a buzz about them now hatefully
the big buzz was about the presentation
of that movie however we did get a
really great Samuel Jackson performance
Kurt Russell had a killer mustache shows
a return a cut Russell in a big that way
he'd already been doing a couple movies
up to that point but that was the year
of Kurt Russell with that bone tomahawk
and then Guardians letting the Guardians
- Quinn Tarantino is a guy who any time
he makes a movie it becomes an event i
love martin scorsese silence should have
been an event it wasn't an event it
wasn't and I hate saying that it is what
isn't brilliant
it was brilliant it was the best movie
of 2019 but what will make the biggest
splash on Twitter so not fair enough but
I don't know
my point is that Tarantino the last
couple movies if we look hatefully I
believe was nominated for Best
Screenplay it's very but because a lot
of people were shocked about that well
but Diego Django inglourious basterds
nominated for Best Screenplay Best
Picture everytime Tarantino comes out
with movie it's not just critically
acclaimed and not just awards acclaim
people seem to love it it usually makes
a lot of people sense of the years the
thing I'd like to I'd like to bring up
with what's about time in Hollywood it's
a complicated Larry it's largely about
it's about gender it's about Hollywood
it's about the filmmaking industry is
quite Tarantino the right guy and I love
Quentin Tarantino movies but he's he the
right guy to tell a story about gender
and Hollywood I mean he had sort of me
two incidents he worked for Harvey
Weinstein there's almost no women cast
in this movie but it just seems like an
awkward fit to have cutey be the guy I
don't know if Ted on tackle 70s
Hollywood gender roles in filming I
don't know if he was the guy who should
have been tackling the death of Hitler
knobs even Jewish but that was a damn
good movie but that's a lot I mean
obviously we're not still talking today
about you know the relevant issues of
Nazism Roman Polanski remains a
controversial figure on social media
yesterday so I'm going and not the case
with inglourious basterds or Django well
I would say what you just said we're not
talking about the most buzzed-about
movies but we're also not talking about
the most welcomed movies of next year I
mean this is how you do it's like this
is a movie about Sharon Tate being
murdered and the opinion of the guy who
lives next order who's like a western
actor it's so dug into this topic
impossible that like the killing of
Hitler and Django burning down that
house this could be another Tarantino
revenge picture where Sharon Tate kills
the [ __ ] out of Charlie Manson possibly
we'll find out let's move to fooling
them Art's not meant to be a pro
final thoughts JT when it comes down to
I think Marvel has become this
well-oiled machine that just knows what
the audience wants and knows what his
fans want now I think with endgame
they've taken their time I mean it's
been a year but they shot both at the
same time yes I just feel like it is the
safest bet to be the most satisfactory
movie of next year the problem I see
with your guys two movies
satisfying is probably with you oh yes
satisfactory satisfied no satisfactory
means like okay fine to me that is the
worst that's gonna do the prime is when
you got Scorsese making a dream project
like this and not really having it
restraints basically here's all the
money you want and send to a tarantino
here's a blank cheque go make your movie
that's when movies like heaven gates get
made and movies like doing gigs in New
York with his brilliance well in your
opinion but overall it's not really seen
that way gangs in New York also smooth
it hasn't really aged well the time now
the dream project to his Spielberg even
had these problems reviews made dream
projects and they just haven't quite
lived up to it so for me I see I've seen
option for both your guys movies to feel
big because they're taking big swings
and they have no restraints Marvel is
produced to be a great movie every
producer that works that studio is
literally gonna be like we need to check
off every box to make sure that this
movie is a hit and that people love it
your guys movies are gonna make big
chances but also has chance at big
failures lon
that's the most passionate and emotional
plea for corporatized [ __ ] boardroom
studio collaborative filmmaking I've
ever don't trust the great artist
don't give the great artists lots of
money and funding instead turn it over
to this group of 35 suits they're gonna
guarantee you final thoughts you used
the word satisfactory never but I think
that's actually what you meant like what
your process is a way to guarantee that
a movie is like above average like okay
I enjoyed that the corporation got
together and collaborate to make sure it
wasn't something I hate it but there's
no chance that a movie made the way that
you've described is going to be
brilliant visionary art that's gonna
break them all in like that's what makes
the standouts among the Marbley so if it
is not that they toed the line exactly
but that they broke away from the
formula it did something different I
think the big the big thing about
endgame is there really aren't a ton of
surprises left this is going to answer
the questions that have already been
posed by the other movies we need it to
transition to the future of the MCU but
this isn't the movie that's going to be
the most amazing epic exciting we just
saw that one infinity war was clearly
the big epic event this is the
resolution to talk about once upon a
time in Hollywood tanti knows movies
they're super fun but so much of the
thrill of it is sort of cheering for the
bad guy the sort of antihero outlaw
character and we're taking a scenario
now where we're looking at a real crime
that had long-term tragic devastating
effects for a number of people who are
still alive it's dealing with all kinds
of issues that are really you know
emotional for people in the present day
I'm just not sure it's the best spot for
Tarantino to do what he does his kind of
campy icky high concept reinvention of
the genre like I enjoy those movies I'm
not sure this is like exactly the right
pick for him and the Irishman you know
we got all hung up on like the
technology that he's gonna use but it's
Martin Scorsese you wouldn't use the
technology he's waited this long to make
this movie because now he can use the
technology that exists to make the movie
he's always going wanted to make I think
there's so much going for this movie I
don't know how you could pick it is the
most eagerly anticipated movie of 2008
thank you on Cameron well I'm not saying
anything you're saying about the
tarantino points are untrue at the same
time I think sometimes art is about
swinging for the fences and sometimes if
you connect hard you connect and you hit
a homerun as far as I'm concerned at
worse Tarantino has hit a triple and if
that's the worst you can do
made a pretty damn good movie think
about Avengers is at the end of the day
part 1 of what is supposed to be the
best movie of next year came out this
year and it wasn't even the best Marvel
movie that came out this year Black
Panther was as far as the Irishman goes
the big question mark on that truly is
Netflix Netflix simultaneously as a
studio that doesn't not buying a movie
that's already been made but as far as
making the movie from the ground up it
has mostly been in the film Department
fairly mists whereas in the TV
Department pretty hit now obviously
there's gonna be some examples there
documentaries are great but as far as
their narrative straight films that they
have built from the ground up which this
is it's been pretty pretty rough going
just as Jodi Hill or a number of the
other people who really see Netflix
movies this year that people didn't even
know came out time alright there you
have it whoo okay
I learned more about the D aging process
the neighbor character max facts um not
a ton of facts if max you got the facts
I got the facts with the facts not a ton
of facts to check here a lot of opinions
that's dumb Cameron did say authentic
thank you she did cry during infinity
war don't ask me how I know that once
upon a time in Hollywood takes place
during the Charles Manson murders but
it's about a TV actor and his stunt
double the next-door neighbor to Sharon
Tate we do know that Margot Robbie's
playing Sharon Tate right well takes
DiCaprio's characters lives next door to
the Tate's and yeah that's kind of
that's kind of all there there was the
check they're pretty clean round all
right yes um games great I'll add that
defect okay again this is all subjective
so there were some strong arguments here
and also I feel like there are some
there was some real parsing over my new
show we got so in the weeds that it was
my it was a little bit like infuriating
that round like we were talking about
such small scale like we spent so much
time on small things that we didn't I
don't feel like we spent enough time on
what excites us about these movies yeah
what's getting us really looking forward
to these movies so going by the
arguments I heard it's a combination I
mean it is subjective what is the best
movie what wears what yeah like we don't
know this is your opinion obviously and
I felt like we we spent a lot of time
dinging each other Cameron got dinged
over some of Tarantino's choices in the
subject matter
lon we got dinged on this passion
project here I don't feel like JT II got
hit as hard and he laid out a strong
argument as to why this movie is going
to be the best to him and for that
reason yeah I'm going jte with Avengers
endgame even though it might not be my
personal choice I feel like that's the
one that got the lease took the least
damage
Danielle I have to disagree if only
because something that you mentioned
which I agree is that I wanted to hear
more just enthusiasm about why this
movie is going to work and I feel like
someone who came with not just a strong
passion for why this is going to be the
best movie but also brought it like
backed it up with just a fantastic
amount of real facts was lon so I've got
to go with one in this round that's one
for lon
max I actually you know what I heard the
most from lon as well and I heard it the
loudest
yeah yeah I feel like Ilan had the most
concrete facts
I feel like JT really just at the end
there with the satisfactory comment let
let it slip a little bit and took them
out and I just heard a little bit more
from lon than from Cameron and both
those movies are sort of similar
director driven but I just heard a
little bit more from lon
lon you get the point hey Walter Mike I
think these are my three most days yeah
emailed it one two yeah oh I am crazily
looking forward to all that's what it
may be even though like sneak sneak in
at the bottom yeah yeah there's a film's
yeah so going into round two one one
Cameron jte looking to get on the board
and whoa stop the presses
whoo-hoo it's a blind fight okay so
first you're going to pick a movie
you're gonna pick a movie out of the Hat
keep it a secret keep it a secret this
water okay that's cuz they are on sticky
notes notes okay now keep your answer a
secret here's the question and then
we'll go around and hear your answer
which 2019 event movie can you skip
seeing in the theaters what massive 2019
film one it just like Oh mark the
calendars that's 110 target which one
are you gonna skip and we're gonna start
with player number two lon Harris which
one are you gonna skip so I mean we're
already at a time where we've got so
many superhero films coming out every
year it's a it's relentless
it never stops I think a lot of people
are starting to get a little bit more
selective about which ones you see in
the theater not even ignore it entirely
they're all part of shared universes but
they're maybe you don't need to rush out
and see and so I think one that is gonna
play as kind of more of a superhero
b-side in 2019 is Zachary Levi as
Shazaam now the thing about Shazam is it
could be fun it seems like they're going
with kind of a comic funny amusing take
on the character but it's probably not
going to be like a three hour IMAX
Aquaman style epic that you feel like I
have to see this on the largest screen
possible there's a movie that I like
it'll be fun when it pops up on Netflix
or you know like the the DC Universe
streaming channel you could maybe wait
for it to come on HBO and you'll still
be able to appreciate it exactly it's
like the sitcom version of the superhero
movie ideal for enjoying in the comfort
of your own home lawns personal choice
of a movie to skip is Shazam DC / cinema
Cameron who get ready everybody in the
comments cuz I'm gonna tell you right
now to skip Star Wars Wow
that's right if you want to sleep at
night and keep your Twitter feed clean
as a whistle
don't even bother seeing this one in the
theater or having an opinion on it
what happened to reg who cares you'll
won't know if you just miss this one did
anybody come back from the dead who can
say you missed an entire happier life by
just not even engaging but beyond that
let's be honest beyond the social media
aspect beyond your own personal
happiness why why skip star wars episode
9 because I think we've seen since the
new trilogy has begun Star Wars is kind
of limited unlike the Marvel movies
where you can see new villains new
worlds Thor is not like Captain America
every one of the spin-off movies on top
of the original truth on the top of the
new trilogy you're seeing the same thing
this is Darkseid the same music all the
motifs the same thing over and over and
over again we already know at this point
Luke's coming back pretty sure it's
coming back as a ghost I think you can
pretty much map out how this movie's
gonna go it's capping off a trilogy and
I believe Daisy relieved and said she
wouldn't go on past nine so I think we
have a pretty good idea what's gonna
happen you could skip this one and have
just up happier life alright it's the
end of a trilogy why not skip it
they work for the Godfather II story
save that for the argument all right
Cameron with Star Wars Episode nine jte
what do you got a huge property being
taken control is when you've already
seen it done well and some of the
promises you know what we're gonna do
this again but we're gonna make it
better we're gonna make it more edgy
more violent maybe it's more closer to
the source material then that trailer
hits and they lied to me how I'm talking
about Hellboy that's right they rebooted
Hellboy can we see your sticker for
proof first of all I saw this trailer
this thing broke two days ago we were
filming this and I literally was sitting
there I was thinking what is this a
sequel to Del Toro's actual trilogy but
without the imagination without the set
design without the creature effects what
am i watching here
David Harbour looks like he literally is
just playing the same exact role that
Ron Perlman did Ron Perlman was one of
the things that made that movie so great
and Del Toro's obviously production
design so when I see this trailer and I
just see laziness and for me these two
movies I mean Shazam is something new
the trilogy the stars it was not just
ending a trilogy there's no reason for
you to see this Hellboy movie yeah III
find it hard to imagine a Neil Marshall
who's a good TV director is gonna class
a Best Picture winning director with del
Toro so for me Hellboy is easily
skippable at best way for Netflix fight
it out y'all
this child like a horror movie I would
be excited looks like Neil Marshall and
they said we want you to do what you do
best but never mind just making me this
album
I'm gonna do something I don't often do
I'm gonna agree with you I think it's a
disappointing trailer but everything
we've heard that they're saying about
the movie does hint that they are taking
it in this different direction and they
made a trailer they don't maybe appeal
to pre standing Hellboy fans so I don't
think we can judge it too harshly
nothing else I've seen about this movie
other than the fact that the trailer was
kind of jokey seems bad and some of the
sequences like when they were in hell
and he's got the sort of horns like that
looks cool that looks like the
old-school Hellboy comic give me an
eighties metal like badass Skaar like it
does look more like the the darker sort
of Gothic Hellboy huh I'll agree with
you to the point where there are some
cool images but nothing that didn't
already show up in these previous two
movies I don't see any these are
different they're good though I thought
two is better than the first one
now if this was a third Deltora Hellboy
movie I'd be psyched but if this is not
on the duration of the other two if it's
if it's a lot like the other two it'll
be fun to see in the theater cuz it'll
be like the other two if it's wildly
going on a different path it'll also be
an awesome McShane reboot if you're just
gonna do the same thing if you're gonna
do something different that's a good
question for the studio does it means
you know affect my enjoyment when I see
it is Shazam is a character we've never
seen on screen before now I'm excited
there's a reason it's ours you've seen
them all before it's basically like a
pastiche Mary but what really drawn me
into that trailer was the comedy the big
s kind of like vibe I had going and that
is something that DC EU needs it needs
some light-hearted managua man is super
jokey and funny humor and comedy
superhero stuff what venom was just
trying to I can't be extravagant it's
goofy most those jokes in that movie do
not land I think Sam has a way of
becoming like I think a real good
sleeper hit I think the simple pitch of
big with a superhero it could be a lot
of fun and it looks like that trailer
has completely nailed it I think you got
a cast so far the writing looks like
it's judging by the trailer
pretty pitch perfect it's funny without
B it's funny and sweet without being
cloying
saccharin two hours it could get it
could where do we know the rooms are I
don't know the movie so you're
definitely there for 100 there's a fact
for Max's yeah well it's a horror movie
director who at this point I think it's
mostly babe movies that kind of range
between 90 to about 110 minutes and the
guy who made lights out this is first
movie he's getting that next shot and
what I appreciate is the fact is that
they're doing the thing that many people
at this table have argued about is like
seeing somebody do a small movie with
lights out do a second little bit bigger
but little small movie with Annabelle -
and now getting the big picture that's
not even that big this isn't a 200
million dollar crazy movie that's
exciting to see you're trying something
out that's great it would be perfect to
watch when it hits Showtime anytime I
think your point about episode 9 might
remove yourself from the fray by
avoiding it you know you're still in the
Internet you're just now you don't know
what everybody's talking about you just
left out the other thing is I think all
of the movies that we've talked about
have rabid intense troll like hateful
awful fans that's not limited to just
Star Wars certainly there are some DC
other comic books you know like all
comic books have this problem personally
sure straining Star Wars isn't gonna
really help you out and you can't defend
the movie you can't fight for truth and
justice if you haven't seen the movie
the world needs to hear your opinion I
believe I think at the end of the day
it's also that fact that JJ's coming
back these two other films are question
marks and a fun way an exciting
different way I love JJ but the man has
not made a good third act ever
a lot of the endings are probably
blaming him for aren't like he was a
producer on it but he like he didn't
write the lost ending shows I'm talking
about the movies he's made he's a super
8 becomes et all of us first Star Trek
has like a big MacGuffin where it's like
this red liquid that's out of nowhere
and I know what Star Trek and sci-fi
it's all this in line with the Star Trek
series pretty science II I think jji God
love the man I think he loves making
first two acts third actors are big
question marks I think the fact that
this I think the fact that he is so
devoted to the series and so loving and
he's also kind of hinted a little bit
like not that he's gonna retract
anything from the last Jedi but kind of
saying like oh don't worry everybody
kind of makes me think like we're gonna
get a fun safe film there's one of the
funds they say it's sort of a
tantalizing question mark start with lon
all of these movies are kind of unknowns
they're not out yet we're still sort of
waiting to hear more but but the two of
them definitely fall into you know sort
of we kind of get where this is sort of
going already
I think helble is kind of the the big
question mark if you if you want to sort
of not know what you're getting into I
feel like we don't know if it's going to
be this darker more interesting more
gritty version or the lighter more
del'toro friendly mark up to new version
my argument there would be it doesn't
matter both of those modes sound fun and
interesting I think anybody who digs
help we would want to see either of
those and definitely it's going to be
big it's going to be visual it's going
to be a feast for the eyes you want to
see it on a big screen
now as for Star Wars we also kind of
know what that's going to be the epic
conclusion to the story that has
captivated audiences around the world
for the past several years like even
people who didn't like the last movie
want to know and see how it ends there's
no way you're gonna want to skip that
one in theatre Shazam
yeah you know it's really where you sort
of know what you're gonna get it's gonna
be kind of funny it's gonna be you know
sort of family appropriate it's gonna be
Zachary Levi being goofy kind of like
the sitcom world combined with the
superhero world it sounds fun but it
also sounds like exactly the sort of
thing that you want to watch I'm like a
lazy Thursday night in your apartment
alright thank you on camera
so I think to me these two films right
here the fact of the matter is is this
is something that I think movie fans
have been kind of screaming for maybe
not these exact movies but mid-tier
budgeted genre films made by fun
interesting genre directors Neil
Marshall and you have the director's
name I cannot recall this movement if
Sandburg thank you David s Sandberg and
that's the thing where you want to see
those chances you want to his question
marks and I would like to give my money
to those two films to be able to say to
Studios yes I want more fun mid-tier
genre pictures you're saying this is the
epic conclusion to the trilogy the fact
of the matter is it's the epic
conclusion to this trilogy yes and then
there's the David Benioff trilogy and
the new Ryan Johnson's trilogy that's
coming and this other film and this
other film the fact that at this point I
think the only thing that's been called
off is the Boba Fett movie where's
everything else I think is still a go
this isn't even like the closing chapter
on anything Star Wars where as if we
don't see Shazam that's it Shazam's over
Hellboy it's very possible much like the
first Hellboy is this hell boy works
maybe this Hellboy 2 is better I would
much rather give to these and just see
what happens
all right lawns gonna watch on Showtime
cameras gonna watch on HBO JT
where are you gonna watch the doors
let's go
for me Star Wars we need that third star
war especially because JJ is doing it so
many people were just they loved that
force awakens
you know Rian Johnson came in and he
pushed the buttons he made some changes
he took some big swings and I think JJ
needs to come back and be like guys I'm
gonna make it okay
the online Star Wars fans are like in
the Civil War everybody he's going in
he's like I'm gonna make the most like
chaotic dangerous movie I can make just
to please everybody I think it's gonna
be a good movie and it's at the end of a
trilogy I got to see it now Hellboy's
had two movies and the reason I was
really excited for Miss Hellboy was
because it was a new character that was
coming to the big screen I don't want to
take that away and Miss Shazam and
somebody's been the DC Comics there's
fans that I've been reading that thing
for way longer than Hellboy and also the
fact that again I just say the DCU needs
that comedy and Zachary Levi looks like
he could be a breakout star he could be
like the DC use Chris Pratt he could
bring that humor and charm but with some
really cool action so for me Shazam is
like the most excited I am for any DC
movie right now that's in the pipeline
so absolutely gosh II am Hellboy again
it's just the same thing and I just feel
like the odds of your on Vegas and your
what are the odds this movies can be
better than Del Toro's it's gonna be
really low I just don't think that Neil
Marshall is he's a good director with
her in genres finding this movie just
feels like when we watch a chair looks
like I've been here I've seen this
there's nothing new even the special
effects but David Herbert and the makeup
don't even look that great dr. oh that's
something you would never say new hawk
del Toro V he knows how to do all those
really cool things and I know for me
Hellboy he's a character who I didn't
really know until the movies and I was
like okay these are interesting but I'm
not clamoring for a new Hellboy movie it
feels like this company had the property
and we're like oh people know Hellboy
let's make another one and see if they
come out let's make it just like the
others so maybe they'll come out even
more so for me Hellboy is just coming
like a cash grab boom that is round two
max what do we got all right so this is
an Shazam is fourteen-year-old boy okay
not a
one time they started they started
screening it yesterday and it's still
not over so it's not released yet so we
don't know how long it is JJ has hinted
recently at retconning some of Ray's
lineage so will need to be seen other
than that McCray is snoke's dad I'm
actually excited for episode 9 max go
ahead and this is a really tough round I
heard a lot of strong arguments all the
way around I have to say that I I feel
like the only way that I can sort of
rationalize it is to give a little
weight to the pic and I feel like
Cameron got the the hardest one in my
opinion and then do the great argument
which was live a happier life by not
engaging an emotional rollercoaster of
episode 8 I feel like I they related to
that and I have to go go Star Wars
alright that's 104 Cameron yeah I feel
like Cameron yeah he sure did pull a
biggie out of the Hat in there but yeah
I mean I feel like he got hit with like
the JJ Abrams thing I didn't the third
act
the lack of third acts working in his
films didn't I don't know it didn't
really speak to me as much as JJ coming
in to kind of heal the rift in the force
that spoke a little bit more to me and
then yeah Shazam is kind of an exciting
new flavor to me I think JT hit it and
like law and even saying that he was
disappointed by the trailer and the fact
that the del Toro movies are beloved so
it might have been the easiest layup of
the bunch but yeah you know JJ he got
the alley-oop and I thought he threw it
down I'm going je te Danielle whoo yeah
I agree also to everyone argued this
fantastically I I am I think I got to go
with Max on this one I'm gonna go
with just it is such a hard difficult
thing and he took he found a way to make
an argument for something that I know
that he's so psyched about but he found
a way to make an argument and to make a
passionate argument that works out of
being given such a difficult choice so
I've got to go ahead and give it to Camp
Tam you get the point
BAM after two rounds Cameron won long
ones jte looking to get on the polls
gonna be a DC movie legend yeah then
let's jump into question number three Oh
everybody's excited for the movie escape
room yes in January
no those early January releases are real
juicy so escape room opens this weekend
what movie would inspire the most
intense escape room experience what
movie would inspire the most intense
escape room experience question number
three
we'll start player three Cameron oh boy
so this is about an escape room is about
using your intelligence making sure you
have the right people you're working
with the right people and you're able to
get out of there some escape rooms are
timed out usually about an hour so my
escape room I had to think about what is
the worst place you would want to
possibly be so the movie I went with is
Monty Python's the meaning of life
specifically the mr. Kristo restaurant
scene and so what happens in this escape
room is you enter the escape room into
the restaurant as mr. Kristo starts
eating and you have an hour before he
explodes and gets his vomit and guts all
over your body now if we want to go
beyond the move beyond this one scene
there's also the other scenes of the
movies such as the stork just dropping
babies all over the place there's a
crazy animated Terry Gilliam sequences
if there was ever an escape room based
on a movie that would be a nightmarish
owl and it's Monty Python's the meaning
of life all right
Cameron was Monty Python's meaning of
life JT this was a difficult question
because I wanted to go for the obvious
like seven or some of these horror
movies I mean saw is basically an escape
room Brent
but I really wanted to queue on the word
intense and I start thinking what are
some of the most intense scenes or
situations in a movie that kind of
resembled an escape room and I start
thinking of the master the Paul T
Anderson film Paul Thomas Anderson film
where there's literally scenes so the
most intense scenes in the past couple
years of my opinion are when Phil super
Hoffman is in a room there's walking
Phoenix it's giving him tests you have
no idea what the hell he's trying to get
I watch you see just scenery just
running from one side of the room the
other and you're just like what the hell
is going on if I was trapped in a room
yelling at me to do these different
trials and tribulations that had no idea
what the hell was going on I would get
mad my partners would get mad this can
be really intense and really frustrating
so for me the master would make the most
intense skipper have you ever stolen
something from someone you loved what is
your choice so I went a little bit of a
different way I feel like these are both
very like they're great choices but
they're very conventional gotta figure
out a few puzzles or whatever I want a
little bit of a different way with it
okay I feel like the most terrifying
thing from filmdom in 2018 would be
preparing to make the movie mission
impossible fallout nobody else is
willing to make movies other than this
than Tom Cruise and it's only because he
thinks he's a real-world superhero and
can't get hurt if Tom Cruise was
rational and realized he could fall off
of this helicopter there's no way he
would do it so I think that's what the
escape room for Mission Impossible Fund
has to capture is you are doing your
you're solving these puzzles in
scenarios that are insane and you
shouldn't be doing them you should get
down from there immediately
so the first puzzle you have to strap
yourself up to the top of the ceiling on
it there you know a 25 okay talk about
the making of them like
the movie not the studio systems while
the room is slowly filling up with water
you know you spy about this movie but
also doing things that are clearly
dangerous inadvisable in an escape room
and like don't do that in an escape room
it's dangerous that's the way you could
really simulate mission impossible
fallout
all right slug it out guys so big you
just look at the trailer for the escape
for a movie and you're saying that
there's the places in the snow and
there's fire and all these other stuff
that's not that since Duvall out what
the falun it's too big I need a I need
city okay say that like one ones thing
that looks like the top of a building
here and one thing that looks like to
have a building here there's no way a
person could jump between them you have
to jump between them just do it I won't
be able to make that what are you not
Tom Cruise did you take place in the
matrix two platforms this room to me
these both sound kind of fun here sounds
like double-dare like could be a really
fun game we put I don't like some
Poncho's like oh man things get explode
out of us anytime it's gonna be
disgusting so it's yours if Mission
Possible had like a building and
Hollywood Boulevard said we're doing an
escape room to promote as you're
possible that's gonna be awesome
I mean intense doesn't mean not fun like
it doesn't mean you hate it just saying
I would go to you know either of those
part of the
was inspired escaping you'd never go to
the most intense escape I understand but
like how can you do Mission Impossible
stuff in a room like it like Tom Cruise
trained to do the halo jump in one of
those simulator we just hover over the
thing for forever intense I get going
Universal Studio City walking they had
those things where you jump in and just
go in the tube and like float around to
be fair you could go to Universal City
clock right now I'd have someone slap
you in the face walk into a Scientology
building be like I said the reason that
Tom Cruise can make those movies is
because he believes he's uber or not
that this would have anything to do with
some might have suicide Taji canisters
based on now here is basically trying to
decide I feel like you go into the
master and you have an actor who's
dressed just like those are often with
the same intensity and the fact that all
you're trying to do is the biggest part
for me when I go to scamper it's a team
work it's working with other people to
solve stuff like Mission Impossible
thing like yeah there's a mystery on it
everybody's got different like
assignments just like the Mission
Impossible theme everybody's got their
little part of the mission and I'm just
saying that they're all deadly and
appear very dangerous and it seems
unsafe and that's the intensity I said
oh this is dangerous a normal person
wouldn't do this but as Tom Cruise I
can't be heard okay I will try escape
room with the potential you're going to
the hospital's attorney it could be a
test but it still has to be something
where I'm not going to fear for my only
you just said it sounded too fun and now
you're saying you're you'd be too late
to go I thought you said I saw the
actual promotion three years it's not
actually I wanted four years we make it
look like it's unsafe so that the
challenge of doing it is scary my room
will have a real person eating so much
food until they die I mean if you
texts are kind of not it's a really
intense experience you're not also like
oh this is hilarious they're in intense
situations
yeah but they do that nervous laughter
not like yes but you are no sacred you
are not watching a screen and my intent
my my survival question for you yeah are
we doing realistic vomit smells oh yeah
oh yeah well so how is anybody working
it they're like all your employees not
vomiting all the time vomit smell your
our there's a documentary out there
there are these horror Halloween rooms
where people will do vomit things and
grab you and I'm not saying it's okay
but people go to it people will pay
money to go do these things if that
sounds intense or just awful I don't
know if I'd be like oh my god it stinks
of vomit here this is so intense because
we both I feel like every like I want to
go anywhere but this room because it
stinks so so the question is not about
the most appealing but it's different
from just vile I think I says what I'm
getting it when I think of ask a broom I
just think of teamwork going into
working with something solving problems
or with your intelligence and not just
you know walking around doing stunts or
worried about something being really
disgusting I want to work with a group
of people and try to solve things and if
I was doing a thing from the master and
each thing is like I don't know where
this is all going to I don't know what
the conclusion is well I have somebody
yelling at me doing things that are
ridiculous this is the problem people
it's kind of the problem your whole
setup is like there's techniques that
he's using in the master they do only
work over a long period of time like it
takes weeks or even months to break down
someone's personality by yelling at them
so if you're going into an escape room
for an hour it's just someone yelling at
you it's not gonna have the same impact
it Philip Seymour Hoffman in the master
because they had a relationship already
that that's why it's so powerful
all right let's change it up final
thoughts Cameron start us off
people love Monty Python
people love escape rooms and becoming
the new biggest thing I think at the end
of the day you combine two things that
people love and it's debatably one of
Monty Python's most famous sketches not
the most but up there it's definitely up
there so how do you combine the comedy
of Monty Python in an escape room you do
the meaning of life to mr. Kristo scene
and it's the our people walking in there
giving food and you and your team have
to try to get out of this restaurant
there's a countdown clock where
eventually this man will explode its
intensity it's funny it's the money
plates on this caper Thank You Cameron
that's a good little commercial for the
micro yeah again I have to go back to
the fact that I just when I've been to
some escape rooms and it's just a bunch
of your friends getting together trying
to solve puzzles and trying to do things
for the intelligence and I think having
the setting of the master like that you
literally have to ask great because I
went today look at they're in the office
you literally be in philip Seymour
Hoffman's office he's there telling you
do things please give me a little
puzzles and you're sitting there you're
like what the hell's this meat and he's
yelling at you so while you're trying to
do these things you're trying to talk to
your friends and your partner's this
guy's like come on I mean just Phil see
we're offering yelling is the best I
don't think you wouldn't yell better the
philistine we're hopping in a movie I
feel like Deb you drove them to your
brain for an hour away trying to solve
all these different puzzles to get out
of the room so you can leave the cult
slash church or whatever he's trying to
get you to be into really interesting
every time I walk down the hollow burner
so just kind of cool promotion like I
said I would totally go to Mission
Possible one that one sounds fun that's
disgusting every time I walk by Church
of Scientology I run good they're
yelling at me trying to come to
something I run my exam like I don't
want to get into the exit too damned
intense get me out of it so you and your
friends are gonna go volunteer thank you
long I just say before I begin I would
really love to see you walking down
Hollywood Boulevard see Scientology the
master is a very intense movie but
because of the performances in the film
making you try to recreate it in some
room with some guy who's making $15 an
hour the same intensity that the great
PT Anderson captures in epitome money by
giving me a life hilarious fun movie not
intense I don't think I've ever watched
a Monty Python sketch film and been like
oh my god this is so intense and you
watching Mission Possible follow
arguably the most intense movie of the
year just think about music playing
while you're trying to solve a puzzle
its intensity incarnate and I'm saying
that this escape room would be as
terrifying as we could make it what's
more intense than having to solve a
puzzle well you're very afraid you're
gonna be asked to uncomfortably choose
between your current crush and your ex
who wants to be in a scenario like that
on an escape room and that sounds
horrible but also intense you also never
know who that other people around you
are they're your real friends are they
in a lifelike mask you don't know it's
the Mission Impossible escape room where
we factually were you talking about
makini manner as the the haunted house
thing might be called Hell house or some
other super intense haunted house and
they're really really real that's a real
thing I would say that the dead parrot
sketch is the most famous money probably
according to Google other than that all
of that that was a bunch of start us off
okay all again another round full of
fantastic arguments I I will say with
with as much as I love Cameron's idea I
feel like he took it away when they were
they were arguing the intensity and he
said yeah but you'll also be laughing
and it's like but like the thing about
laughter is tension and release if you
release the tension then it's no longer
intense good point um and then nothing
to fight this fight I guess I'm fighting
it now and speaking of comedy I like you
know I love your idea jce was great
until you'd mentioned you'll be talking
with your friends while someone's
yelling at you that's just going to a
bar at a comedy show pops up
we only know what we know that's
slightly more irritating but intense the
idea of you trying to do things with
your friends while some dude yells in
your ear and so um you know just the
thought of trying to leap off of things
and float off things while solving
puzzles and a romantic triangle I just
sound pretty intense although I will let
my exes die one for lon who is bringing
that mask-making technology into real
life Wolf Blitzer shows exists how could
they put valiant arguments all around I
am actually gonna go
despite their strong areas all around I
think
lon made some really strong cases
there's that there's definitely those
physical things are really intense but I
feel like JT where the fact that you
don't even know what the point is that
seems like the most intense you don't
even understand the question so I'm
gonna go JT
okay so that's uh that's one four one
four lon one for JT yeah you guys each
presented something interesting yeah
Cameron I thought your choice was strong
because tick tick tick tick is he's
getting bigger and bigger but then the
fed I I think Danielle brought up a good
point the laughter does defuse the
intensity a little bit and JT yours was
inspired by the movie but also your
dislike about
like you could have just made join the
Scientology escape and I only became
that because we ventured out to
Hollywood you were like free like you
weren't even talking about Joaquin
Phoenix you were just like imagine this
was walking down walk that a great ding
on you it's like a $15 an hour character
so some good cheap you know what there's
a lot of non-working actors out there
keep going for the dream I'm at the end
of the day that leaves even though it
was a little there was a little murky
just as far as like this they're like
how you would physically make this occur
there was there was enough there that
delivered the highest degree of
intensity lawn getting a point how would
you physically irradiate a glacier such
that it poisons a third of the world you
couldn't that could really happen I mean
I feel like the only limits are our
imagination so jte great effort and man
I love some of your answers but you will
be on the sidelines going into the speed
round man oh all right so is lon
with two points Cameron with one point
and it's time for that speed round all
right so the speed round works thusly I
will ask the question shout out your
answers the first answer that I hear
that individual will get to elaborate on
their answer first and you'll get 20
seconds 20 seconds and then 10 second
rebuttal ten second rebuttal first
player to four points takes the day and
it's two-to-one lon
going into question one of the speed
round you all ready for this mm-hmm
let's do it
question 1 what will be the worst movie
of 2019 Angry Birds 2
I'm gonna go with cats okay we heard
Angry Birds to first lawn has cats
Cameron whenever you're ready
every birds one was already ten years
behind the trend of Angry Birds being a
big deal is a terrible movie people even
forgot it was coming out but apparently
did well enough I guess to get a sequel
so if you're getting a sequel to a 10
year old trend to old movie that no one
even wanted does it really exist I guess
it does and that makes it even worse
than bad is if it's just there like a
nothingness in the wind in the cgi verse
of terrible movies cats is coming to us
from Tom Hooper the director of the
horrible failed lame his adaptation that
no one likes and now he's taking
arguably an even more challenging plate
to adapt to play that doesn't even
really have a plot it's just a bunch of
characters cutting cats coming out and
introducing themselves and now we're
going to watch several hours of this and
it stars people like rebel Wilson I urge
you just sold me an amazing sounding
weird crazy film from a weird crazy
director and as we see with Aquaman it
sounds like that's gonna make a lot of
money and make many people very happy
weird is great Angry Birds 2 is just
gonna be there nothing that's boring and
your birds 2 is a movie sort of out of
time which I agree with that doesn't
mean it's going to be bad it just means
that it's kind of not hitting the
culturally relevant moment but there's
lots of movies like the lego ninjago
movie wasn't
culturally relevant but is still fun
alright whoo how about it let's go to
max I'm not looking forward to seeing
either of these movies I think I got a
couple more things from lon just the
description of what the movie might be
like and then also just Tracker go to
the director I think I'll go with long
boom that is one for long I'm uh I
actually feel I felt the flip on this
one i I thought Cameron laid out just
why the first one didn't work and why
the second one is going to be just more
of
that thing that he didn't want and more
of that so because of that I'm going
Cameron Danielle um yeah I have to agree
I feel like Cameron laid out why Angry
Birds 2 is going to be boring
and then why you know you did
blondie did a great job of making that
movie sound weird and Cameron agreed
with you and I would much rather watch a
weird movie where rebel Wilson
introduces herself as a cat been
watching my phone app come to life for
the swearing do not differ I agree it
was the it was um the weird versus like
the dead on arrival and like yeah if I
between those two choices go the way
Cameron you get that point we're all
tied up it's a great moment in sports
weird weird fun and then you go to a
theater and you're like no we're not
Tucker oh no I do it's Jason Derulo
that's the question I'm in all in all
right Hudson Isabelle oh they just you
keep going down you're like wait Judi
Dench Sabha Aegis Elba is in this okay
maybe he's mechanics you know gee I hear
they're gonna be coming who knows my
friend I might go see that but I'm not
gonna see any slingshotted Birds okay
kill those pigs there's a lot of movies
that came out the year of the first
Angry Birds that were worse than it all
right I'm looking forward to the emoji
movie part two
okay we got our first look at Will Smith
as the genie from the upcoming Aladdin
it happened this week it has a filming
remember that you guys int okay so we
saw blue Smith has the genie in Aladdin
which franchise would be most improved
by Will Smith wrapping the plot of the
movie over the end credits franchise or
movie which franchise or movie okay I'm
gonna open it up John I'm gonna go
Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy okay yes
Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy hmm kam avatar
avatar all right
James Cameron's 3d epic versus the Gary
Oldman spy thriller
we heard you first lon here's the thing
Taylor Taylor Soldier Spy is great it's
very stylish true it's got a lot of good
performance it's it's very complicated
it's so complicated I think that keeps a
lot of people and in arms let they have
a gun into the movie to enjoy the things
are great about it because they don't
quite understand everything that's going
on enter Will Smith with a perfect easy
to understand rap that sums up all the
action that you just saw says the next
time you watch a movie and eat your cut
up people talk about James Cameron's
Avatar wooden things they bring up is
that it's not memorable in the fact of
the matter is that sometimes James
Cameron's best movies had memorable
soundtracks he had Guns'n'Roses in
Terminator 2
he had Celine Dion and Titanic the thing
that avatar was truly missing was a
bitchin song and I think we all know
Will Smith in the 90s knew how to make
some great songs I think the one thing I
returned to you was a great theme song
done by Big Willie style himself The
Fresh Prince of bel-air I mean what we
learned in the nineties is even when the
songs are probably don't necessarily
confer popularity on to the films like
Wild West being the prime example of a
song everybody remembers a movie that
nobody saw so I don't know I don't know
if that really holds the name of the
song would be ICU it would be all about
Jake Sully the fact of the matter is
beyond the great title Tinker Tailor
Soldier Spy I don't know what he would
rap about the movie itself is
complicated he needs to rap about the
plot that's how Will Smith works avatar
simple plot you know what I gotta go
with long yeah there are several words
to rhyme with their Tinker Tailor
Soldier Spy and it was a complicated
plot and you're pitching a theme song we
were talking about wrapping the plot of
the movie over the end credits so yeah
Milan's got it for me Danielle yes got
oh great specifically like that as much
as I you did have a great point with the
those great James Cameron soundtracks
but if it's about wrapping the plot Lord
knows a lot of us could use some help
three times and I'd still like to hear
I'm already stuff like it former where
it's just like telling in foam okay LAN
you get that point it is free to what
move you would you have wanted to see
will be wrap over no I think now maybe
part of the Caribbean thank you know a
lot to say the fact that he never did
one for any of the bad boys soundtracks
is a little I feel like bad boys for
life yeah we shall see hopefully that
will happen this is game point right
here lon you take this you take the game
Kevin you need this to mean we're going
what movie character would throw the
sickest New Year's Eve party
what movie character would throw out the
sickest New Year's Eve party jordan
belfort the wolf of Wall Street
Jordan Belfort the wolf of Wall Street
Thanos Jordan Belfort down
loved beautiful like jordan belfort
first mom Jordan Belfort's whole life is
organized around parting the parting is
more important than than the business
that he's supposed to be running
throughout the movie he's gonna put so
much time and effort and money he's
gonna spend everything that's because
the point is to show up he wants to show
you how much wealth he has show you how
impressive he is so he's gonna make this
party totally sick to impress everybody
who shows up that's the whole point he's
giving speeches there's like crazy
people doing stunts the whole entire
movie the whole point of that movie is
that he's non-stop partying you see the
downfall it gets sad he's gonna throw a
party it's way too long Thanos was gonna
throw a party he's gonna change where
you're at he's gonna take you to
different times you got a friend who's
not there Boop now they're there all of
a sudden you need to get high you're not
high enough move now you're suddenly
stones do you've ever been in your life
party's gonna be sick Jordan Belfort is
gonna talk your ear off but the very
worst anos might just be a little grumpy
jordan belfort sample codes after months
and months a party he's not having his
downfall all on New Year's Eve while I'm
at the party I get to enjoy the high
part and I don't have to be there for
the tipping downhill in the 80s
destruction of everything that's great
make sure you don't bring anybody with
you they care about the chances are
Jordan Belfort is gonna talk they're up
he's gonna be terrible to them if you
bring a girlfriend he's gonna try to do
something terrible she's not gonna want
any of that
sano said the very worst might just tell
you about his life philosophy
okay
time time Wow
I wouldn't go to either of these guys so
when mom picked Jordan I was like oh
that's the great answer he's definitely
gonna get this and then Thanos come on
she's throwing the party he wants you to
be there if you're invited I gotta go
you know it's as much as I really do
appreciate that you don't want to bring
a loved one to jordan belfort
I do think he's gonna be that dude the
talk sugar often is gonna be super
annoying and maybe slightly
inappropriate I did have to agree that I
thought that law and had a great
comeback with that by saying oh I don't
have to be there when things get bad I
can leave any time to leave here he was
sad bad life and so because of that I've
got to go with mom yeah once the ludes
come out that's when I'm all right so
it's one one you know what here's the
thing all I know about your dude Cameron
is that he killed half of all em efforts
I've never seen a party
question wasn't about real partiers the
sickest party I don't even know if he's
capable this is all hypothetical this
dude knows how to party
he is socially and morally reprimanded
but if there's one thing that he could
do it's party one gets that point lon
well fought all day long even if you did
go a little too far down the rabbit hole
of that anti-age it's true
well-played good sir and hoot-hoot to
you please give us a shout outs etc
oh look follow me on Twitter at L ons
check out a you know movie fights every
week or a screech ugh is also right too
much of our video so watch stuff on
screen junkies and uh yeah have a great
new year everybody it already is um yeah
I will second that follow on Twitter
always tweeting a lot of funny so yeah I
really enjoy your feed good sir Cameron
I enjoyed you today you took it to the
limit and bizarre choices a lot of those
are choices good to know that you will
be staying at home when Star Wars
Episode nine
please tell us where we can find you and
anything yeah coming up
Jaime on twitter.com slash Jurassic
alien and also over at hyper RPG I have
a show over there that I do on Tuesday
nights and also go check out my
photography Instagram it's cameras
photos I taken photos of a Dalton JT's
dog jte I'm you know what I'm so good
I'm back I'm sad I didn't get to see you
in the speed round but I'm happy that I
did not see you tear anyone's neck oh
wow yeah this was great it's been a
while since I found movie fights I felt
a little rusty but I just love doing the
show I love talking movies and arguing
and like this is what me in line I
usually do we usually agree most time
but we good yeah follow me on YouTube
and Twitter
JT movie thinks oh yeah follow my dog
Dalton the Bulldog this guy's into some
really great photos great photographer
hire him if you can yeah I'll second
this guy always cranking out some really
fun movie reviews actually yeah always
enjoy your thoughts and opinions thanks
JT um max thanks for holding it down on
the factual --'tis no problem you can
find me on twitter at max Deon sometimes
I'll tweet my opinions on things
sometimes I won't treat for weeks at a
time world fallen Kingdom sure we're
wearing like a Christmas themed shirt
today in 2019 oh you realized right that
was like inappropriate cuz it was like
well where Christmas is over so I
changed this promotional Jurassic world
shirt my favorite movie
nicely done Max's favorite of all
dressed
for this because I love it so much
Danielle Radford man she is just killing
it in the new year
on fire tell people where they can find
you yeah you can find me on twitter at
daniel Radford on instagram at danielle
underscore Radford you can find me at my
patreon where we do really fun chat
alongs I'm trying to set up some some
fun stuff for that that we'll be doing
in this the new year and you can find me
at Hal Rudnick on Instagram and Twitter
this is Percival the owl hashtag owl
nation hashtag Percival the album hoot
yes come to my Instagram and Twitter for
all things movie TV owl and just lots of
just stupid nonsense and I want to thank
you for watching today appreciate it I
hope you're having a great new year so
far or maybe your year is already
terrible so you know if it's three days
in there like oh screw it I'll see you
in 2020 Thanks thank you so much thanks
to Billy holding it down in the booth
today and doing double D as our esteemed
producer and we'll see you next time bye
bye
you